with reaction counselor to the president
Kellyanne Conway I know I'm long-winded
but I feel very passionately it's time
to stop the nonsense Americans are
suffering here they need jobs they want
to get out of poverty want to get off of
food stamps and is an easy path out what
is the media missing they're missing the
fact that you have Democratic senators
like Heidi Heitkamp willing to stand
with the president today join him to her
home state of North Dakota why because
she knows 73% of North Dakotans support
tax reform and that's a state that
Donald Trump one running on tax reform
and tax relief by 36 points then you
look at a state where Joe Manchin in
West Virginia is up for re-election next
year as well that's the state Bill
Clinton carried by 15 points in 1996 and
20 years later Donald Trump carried the
state by almost 43 points because he ran
as a limited government conservative
who's going to cut taxes repeal and
replace Obamacare strengthen our borders
keep us processors and safe now you
raise a very important point
many Americans Shawn wants a dignity of
work they want to be self-sufficient
they want to know that they have high
paying jobs that are stable and secure
the best way to do that really is to
lower taxes to lower taxes on our job
creators our job holders and our job
seekers and also to repatriate all this
wealth that is legally parked offshore
we want to bring the jobs and the wealth
back to this country this is very simple
the president laid it out today I think
North Dakota is an inspiring economic
example to the country if not the world
of what happens when you allow energy
production when you allow
entrepreneurship on Genuity
competitiveness we have to make our
employers competitive so that they can
attract and retain an American workforce
the offshoring model under our current
tax code does not work our offshoring
model means that we punish American
companies for doing business here and it
forces them to shift the jobs in the
wealth overseas the American model under
President Trump simplifies the tax code
makes it more fair give the middle class
tax cut repatriate set wealth and makes
our employers more competitive this is
easy stuff there's not a Republican in
the house or the Senate
and probably the governorship state
legislatures and there are many
Democrats as well who ran on this and
ought to be able to pass it make good on
their promise I'm more angry at
Republicans but this is my own personal
thing mr. 18 percent approval rating
Mitch McConnell and I don't want to
exasperate him he said Oh expectations
are so high he had eight months to do
health care and couldn't get it done I
want to ask you about the brain-dead
robots in my profession in the media
because did you notice the cruel cruel
cruel quote I played a montage on radio
that went on for minutes they all use
the same word is it by accident or by
design do they all like tweet each other
let's use the word cruel today well
there's a certain safety and sameness
going on and much of the coverage and I
don't think that benefits the viewers
and the readers much either if they just
hear the same lexicon the same coverage
the same point of view and very few
facts and figures and when it comes to
daca we really need to talk about the
facts here the Attorney General and DHS
both concluded that there is no
constitutional statutory authority for
daca and that rather than take the
chance and being sued by these nine
state attorneys general take the chance
that what happened to DAP but would
happen to daca in that you would have an
immediate rescinding of the program of
the measure the president went a
different route he provided a longer
runway a six-month wind-down giving
people notice and augering for a more
orderly and efficient process
you know I like to I like to contrast it
to the Travel Hall earlier in the year
where the same people were up in arms
about that that actually does have
statutory and constitutional authority
in addition to the constitutional
authority for the president 8th US Code
1882 gives a president broad authority
to under our immigration system to take
action where he sees fit so there you
actually have a statute to read they
refused to do that here there is no
statute to read and they refuse to
acknowledge that - but look President
Obama himself admitted something that we
agree with completely six years later
that it is Congress who makes the laws
in this country Sean that includes the
immigration laws so Congress feel so
compelled to act
let's start a trend in Congress then act
if they if they want to if they want to
make the doctor cover don't do that but
you know if they don't they don't but
this president
he's waiting pen in hand he's even
willing to consider repealing and
replacing Obamacare he's ready he's a
businessman who's accustomed to doing
many big things in short order doesn't
really understand why the swamp and the
special interest move at a different
pace I I don't get a listen I don't get
it either
I I don't live in their world of you
know vacations every other weekend and
to find Senate dining room and workout
rooms and all right I'll keep you out of
it you work in the White House I'll save
that for myself Kelley and great to see
you as always you Sean